GOT AN EARLY TEAR ON THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER ACCUSATION
.
CALIFORNIA LEARNED ABOUT THE
SO-CALLED WHISTLE-BLOWER, THAT
WAS A BLOWER IS CONCERNED BEFORE
HE OR SHE FILED THE COMPLAINT.
IN FACT, SPEAK 24'S OFFICE SPOKE
DIRECTLY TO THE FUTURE
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER WHISTLE-BLOWER
AND EVEN THE WHISTLE-BLOWER HE
OR SHE HIRE AN ATTORNEY, MEET
WITH THE INSPECTOR GENERAL TO
FIRE DOMINIC FILE A COMPLAINT.
HIS BITTERNESS
FINGERPRINTS ALL OVER IT.
WE HEARD IT FROM SO-AND-SO, THAT
WOULD NOT BE ADMISSIBLE IN A
COURT OF LAW, BUT I'M INHERENTLY
AND NOT A COURT OF CORRUPT
DEMOCRATS WHO SPREAD LIES AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES OF ONE HOAX
AFTER ANOTHER, AND THE
SLEAZEBAGS THAT COWARDLY SCHIFF
HIMSELF WAS BEHIND THIS
"NONPARTISAN, TOTALLY LEGITIMATE
WHISTLE-BLOWER COMPLAINT FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING."
THIS CAN'T BE THE SAME COWARDLY
SCHIFF WHO FROM CALIFORNIA WHO
ACTUALLY WENT ON CONSPIRACY
TELEVISION, AREA 51, ROZ WELL
RACHEL'S NETWORK MSNBC SEPTEMBER
RACHEL'S NETWORK MSNBC SEPTEMBE2
RACHEL'S NETWORK MSNBC SEPTEMBE6
RACHEL'S NETWORK MSNBC SEPTEMBEA
RACHEL'S NETWORK MSNBC SEPTEMBED
RACHEL'S NETWORK MSNBC SEPTEMBEC
RACHEL'S NETWORK MSNBC SEPTEMBEA
RACHEL'S NETWORK MSNBC SEPTEMBEM
RACHEL'S NETWORK MSNBC SEPTEMBED
RACHEL'S NETWORK MSNBC SEPTEMBE,
RACHEL'S NETWORK MSNBC SEPTEMBEQ
RACHEL'S NETWORK MSNBC SEPTEMBEO
RACHEL'S NETWORK MSNBC SEPTEMBEE
RACHEL'S NETWORK MSNBC SEPTEMBE,
WE HAVE NOT SPOKEN TO THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
A LIE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE NOT SPOKEN DIRECTLY
WITH THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
WE WOULD LIKE TO.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER HAS NOT BEEN
AS DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE HOW TO COMMUNICATE
WITH CONGRESS.
>> Sean: LYING THROUGH HIS
TEETH, CAUGHT AGAIN.
THE SHIFTY SCHIFF, PRACTICALLY
HOLDING THE WHISTLE ON THE
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER.
THE SAME CON ARTIST WHO IS NOW
LEADING THE DEMOCRATS' IDIOTIC
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY, WHICH IS
TOTALLY BASED ON THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER COMPLAINT THAT
THE SHIFTY SCHIFF HIMSELF HAD A
HAND IN CREATING, CLEARLY.
OFFERING ADVICE TO.
THIS IS WHY AMERICANS HATE THE
SWAMP KNOWN AS WASHINGTON, D.C.
THE LEAKING, LYING, THE SKI
INCOME OF THE CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION.
ALL OF IT FROM SCHIFF, A
DISGUSTING ABUSE OF POWER.
BY THE WAY, HE NOW NEEDS TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
HE MUST BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
WE ARE CALLING TONIGHT FOR AN
INDEPENDENT ETHICS INVESTIGATION
INTO THE OFFICE OF THE COWARDLY
ADAM SCHIFF.
HE MUST IMMEDIATELY NOW RECUSE
HIMSELF FROM ANY IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY AND IT IS TIME THAT THIS
LIAR GO UNDER OATH ABOUT HIS
INVOLVEMENT IN    IN THE PHONY
WHISTLE-BLOWER REPORT.
EVERY AMERICAN WHO VOTED, YOU'VE
GOT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
YOU VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP, YOU
ARE A SMELLY WALMART SHOPPER
LIKE ME.
I THINK IT'S SMART TO SHOP AT
WALMART.
YOU SAVE MONEY.
YOU ARE INDEED DEPLORABLE AND
YOU ARE A BITTER AMERICAN WHO
CLINGS TO THEIR GOD, BIBLE,
RELIGION, SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS.
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND TONIGHT
THAT CORRECT CONGRESSMEN IS
WILLING TO DO ALMOST ANYTHING TO
REMOVE A DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT,
THE PRESIDENT YOU VOTED FOR, HIS
DERANGED LYING, CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, ARE NOW CATCHING UP TO
HIM.
HE'S NOT FIT TO SERVE A CONGRESS
AT ALL, THE CHAIRMAN OF THIS
COMMITTEE, WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS
NOTHING NEW.
IT'S THE SAME SCHIFF, DIFFERENT
DAY.
AS CONGRESSMAN JORDAN POINTED
OUT, THIS IS SPEAK 24'S PATTERN,
HAS A HAND ON EVERY A
CONSPIRATORIAL ANTI-TRUMP SMEAR
BROUGHT TO CONGRESS.
FOR EXAMPLE, SUMMER 2018, THERE
WAS THE SHIFTY SCHIFF, A SECRET
MEETING WITH FUSION GPS, GLENN
SIMPSON, THE GUY ROBERT NEWELL
HE NEVER HEARD OF.
SIMPSON, WHOSE FIRM WAS BEHIND
THE DIRTY DOSSIER WAS AN
IMPORTANT WITNESS IN HIS
COMMITTEES INVESTIGATION INTO
COLLUSION THAT'S BEEN DEBUNKED
FOUR TIMES.
REMEMBER, SCHIFF IS TEAM?
THEY PREPPED MICHAEL COHEN
BEFORE HIS COMMITTEE ON
CAPITOL HILL.
WOW.
IT APPEARS THAT THE COWARDLY
SHIFTY SCHIFF PLAYED A VITAL
ROLE IN COORDINATING A
WHISTLE-BLOWER COMPLAINT.
WHETHER IT INVOLVES RUSSIA,
UKRAINE, MAYBE IT'LL BE THE
BAHAMAS IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY
NEXT.
IT SEEMS THAT COWARDLY SCHIFF
HAS BEEN PLOTTING THE
PRESIDENT'S DESTRUCTION,
UNDERMINE YOUR LOVE BOAT, LYING
THE
THE ONLY PROBLEM WITH HIS
STRATEGY WAS IT WAS ALWAYS BUILT
ON A PACK OF LIES.
THIS IS THE GUY WHO FABRICATED A
TRANSCRIPT.
THE GUY, YOU DIDN'T KNOW, HE WAS
BEING PRAYING AND TALKING TO A
REAL RUSSIAN ABOUT DIRT ON
DONALD TRUMP THAT HE COULD USE
DURING AN ELECTION.
BY THE WAY, IT WAS READ OUT LOUD
IN THE OFFICIAL COMMITTEE
HEARING.
YOU DON'T REMEMBER, -- "THE
NAKED PICTURES."
DOES VLADIMIR KNOW?
MY GOSH.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE IS ALREADY IN MY VIEW
AMPLE EVIDENCE, IF YOU ARE
WILLING TO SEE IT.
IF YOU WANT TO BLIND YOURSELF,
YOU CAN LOOK THE OTHER WAY.
>> I CAN CERTAINLY SAY WITH
CONFIDENCE THAT THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE CAMPAIGN
IN RUSSIA.
>> I'VE BEEN CLEAR THE LAST YEAR
AND YEAR AND A HALF THAT THERE
IS AMPLE EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
IN PLAIN SIGHT.
>> Sean: FOUR SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS, NO EVIDENCE OF
ANYTHING.
LIE AFTER LIE AFTER LIE AFTER
LIE.
IT IS AS GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY?
KEEP IN MIND IT WAS ACTUALLY THE
COWARDLY SCHIFF CAUGHT ON TAPE
COLLUDING WITH RUSSIA.
DOES VLADIMIR SEE IT?
"OF COURSE, VLADIMIR HAS NAKED
PICTURES OF TRUMP."
HE WAS BEING FRANK, DOING WHAT
HE'S ACCUSED TRUMP OF.
BUT I THOUGHT DEMOCRATS WERE
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT FOR AN
ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
I GUESS THAT ONLY INVOLVES
FICTIONAL CLAIMS AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP, NOT THE DIRTY
DOSSIER, BECAUSE IF THEY REALLY
CARED ABOUT COLLUSION OR
INTERFERENCE, WHEREAS THE
COWARDLY SCHIFF'S HYSTERIA OVER
HILLARY CLINTON'S DIRTY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
FINALLY CONCLUDED LIKELY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION FROM THE START.
WHERE IS THE THIS HYSTERIA OVER
THE DNC IS YOU COLLUSION WITH
UKRAINE?
THE DNC PRESSED THE UKRAINIAN
MNC TO DIG UP DIRT ON
DONALD TRUMP DURING THE 2016
ELECTION.
THERE IS MORE IN THE SAME
REPORT.
TRY TO HELP HILLARY CLINTON
UNDER THE
THEY ALSO DISSEMINATED DOCUMENTS
IMPLICATING A TOP TRUNK AID
ONLY TO BACK AWAY AFTER THE
ELECTION.
THEY PICKED THE WRONG HORSE AND
THEY HELPED HILLARY CLINTON'S
ALLIES DAMAGE RESEARCH ON TRUMP
AND HIS ADVISORS.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
THAT WOULD BE FOREIGN ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
BUT, ACCORDING TO A REPORT FROM
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," WELL,
WE HAVE TO GO REPUBLICAN
SENATORS, NOT DEMOCRATS, WHO ARE
DEMANDING ANSWERS INTO "THE
BRAZEN EFFORTS BY THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE AND
HILLARY CLINTON AND HER CAMPAIGN
TO USE THE GOVERNMENT OF UKRAINE
FOR THE EXPRESSED PURPOSE OF
FINDING NEGATIVE INFORMATION ON
THEN CANDID AND TRUMP IN ORDER
TO UNDERMINE HIS CAMPAIGN."
THAT'S THE EXACT THING THAT THEY
QUOTE THAT TRUMP HAS DONE TWICE.
IT'S SICK, FRANKLY DESTRUCTIVE
AND PSYCHOTIC AT THIS POINT.
YOU'VE GOT THE SPEAKER IN NAME
ONLY PELOSI, YOU'VE GOT THE
COWARDLY SHIFTY SCHIFF, THEIR
POWERS IN THE MEDIA MOB WITH THE
ONLY EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
THEY ARE PUTTING THEIR AGENDA
AHEAD OF WHAT'S TRUTHFULLY,
HONEST, WHAT AMERICAN PEOPLE
KNOW.
THE REAL ABUSE OF AMERICAN
POWER, THE REAL WEAPONIZATION OF
THE AMERICAS INTELLIGENCE
SYSTEM, AND PFIZER
FISA FRAUD, THREE
LONG YEARS HYPERVENTILATING
TELLING US THEY HAVE THE TRUTH
ONE HOAX AFTER ANOTHER, ONE LIE
AFTER ANOTHER, ONE CONSPIRACY
AFTER ANOTHER, RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA.
NOW IT'S UKRAINE, UKRAINE,
UKRAINE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE PRESIDENT CALLED ON THE
RUSSIANS TO HELP IN THIS
CAMPAIGN BY HACKING AND
HILLARY'S EMAILS.
>> WE ARE USING THIS AS LEVERAGE
TO OBTAIN DIRT.
ANOTHER COUNTRY MANY FACTOR DIRT
ON HIS OPPONENT.
>> WE BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES ENGAGED IN A
COVER-UP.
>> I THINK THAT THERE IS
EVIDENCE OF A COVER-UP.
>> THE CAMPAIGN ACCEPTED HELP.
THE RUSSIANS GAVE HELP AND THE
PRESIDENT MADE FULL USE OF THAT
HELP.
>> I DO NOT THINK WE CAN RELY ON
A COUNTRY BEHOLDEN ON THE GOOD
GRACES OF DONALD TRUMP TO BE
ABLE TO LEVEL WITH US ON THIS.
>> NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW,
ESPECIALLY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THE PRESIDENT BELIEVES THAT HE
IS ABOVE THE LAW.
THE LAW BEING THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> THERE IS ALREADY IN MY VIEW
AMPLE EVIDENCE IN THE PUBLIC
DOMAIN ON THE ISSUE OF COLLUSION
IF YOU ARE WILLING TO SEE IT.
>> IT IS VERY POWERFUL EVIDENCE
OF THAT KIND OF POTENTIAL
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> Sean: DO YOU SEE A PATTERN?
IT WOULD ALMOST BE FUNNY IF THEY
WEREN'T TRYING TO CIRCUMVENT THE
WILL OF YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, AND LITERALLY REMOVE A
DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT FROM
OFFICE WHO IS DOING AN AMAZING
JOB UNDER THE WORST
CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND SMEARING THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN THEIR NUMBER ONE GOAL FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING.
BY THE WAY, THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT IMPROVING THE LIVES OF
AMERICANS, IN SPITE OF THEIR
LOFTY AND, YOU KNOW, CLICHED
LANGUAGE FROM EARLIER TODAY.
AS THE PRESIDENT TWEETED, THE
DO-NOTHING DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON BUILDING UP OUR
COUNTRY, NOT WASTING EVERYONE'S
TIME AND ENERGY ON B.S., WHICH
IS WHAT THEY'VE BEEN DOING EVER
SINCE I GOT OVERWHELMINGLY
ELECTED IN 2016, GET A BETTER
CANDIDATE THIS TIME.
YOU'LL NEED IT.
BY THE WAY, WE HAVE AN ELECTION
IN A YEAR.
DO YOU THINK YOUR IDEAS ARE
SUPERIOR, DO YOU THINK YOUR
RECORD IS BETTER?
OKAY, LET'S HAVE IT OUT IN THE
RING CALLED AN ELECTION.
HAVE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DECIDE
FOR ONCE AND MAYBE YOU GUYS CAN
PUT YOUR BEST CANDIDATE FORWARD
WHO WANTS TO SPEND $94 TRILLION
AND ELIMINATE GAS, OIL, ENERGY,
THE COMBUSTION ENGINE, PLANES,
COWS.
RUN ON THAT $94 TRILLION IDIOCY
IN THE ELIMINATING PRIVATE
INSURANCE, GOOD LUCK WITH THAT.
THE PRESIDENT CONTINUED TO FIGHT
BACK AGAINST THOSE WHO WANT TO
TAKE HIM DOWN.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE DON'T COLUMN SHIFTY SCHIFF
FOR NOTHING.
HE'S A SHIFTY, DISHONEST GUY.
BY THE WAY, WHO IS CRITICAL OF
ONE OF THE GREAT SECRETARY OF
STATE, GRADUATED NUMBER ONE IN
HIS STAGE AT WEST POINT,
GRADUATED TOP -- ONE OF THE TOP
OF HIS CLASS AT HARVARD LAW
SCHOOL.
THE MOST HONORABLE PERSON, MIKE
POMPEO.
THIS GUY WAS NEGATIVE ON MIKE
HE CAN'T -- THERE IS AN
EXPRESSION.
HE COULDN'T CARRY HIS BLANKET
STRAP.
I WON'T SAY IT, IT'S SO TERRIBLE
TO SAY.
HE WOULDN'T CARRY HIS BLANK
STRAP.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND THAT?
YOU DEAL WITH BAD PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW?
I WATCHED CHINA OVER THE LAST
FEW DAYS AND WATCH THESE OTHER
COUNTRIES BUILD UP, BUILD UP,
BUILD UP, AND WE BUILD UP MORE
THAN ANY OF THEM BECAUSE OF ME,
BUT NO HELP FROM THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE A DISASTER.
THEY ARE THE DO-NOTHING
DEMOCRATS, THEY DON'T DO ANY
WORK, ALL THEY WANT TO DO IS TRY
TO WOULD MAKE THE ELECTION IN
2020 SO THEY COME UP WITH THIS
IMPEACHMENT NONSENSE AND
EVERYONE KNOWS, THE CONVERSATION
ALL BASED ON ONE PHONE CALL THAT
I HAD WHERE I'M TALKING TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UKRAINE, YOU'LL
HEAR FROM AMBASSADORS, YOU'LL
HEAR FROM SOME OF THE FOLKS WHO
KNOW ALL ABOUT THE CALL, WHY THE
CALL WAS SET UP, AND EVERYTHING
ELSE IS PERFECT.
THE CALL WAS PERFECT.
NANCY PELOSI AND SHIFTY SCHIFF,
WHO SHOULD RESIGN IN DISGRACE,
BY THE WAY, AND JERRY NADLER AND
ALL OF THEM, IT'S A DISGRACE
WHAT'S GOING ON.
AND WE SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON
MAKING AMERICA GREAT AGAIN AND
KEEPING AMERICA GREAT BECAUSE
WHAT THEY DID WAS NONSENSE.
THINK OF IT.
YOU HAVE A PERFECT -- I MEAN,
PERFECT CONVERSATION WITH A
PRESIDENT OF ANOTHER COUNTRY,
UKRAINE IN THIS CASE.
AND THEY TRY AND SAY, LET'S
IMPEACH HIM.
THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO IMPEACH
ME FROM THE DAY I GOT ELECTED.
I HAVE BEEN GOING THROUGH THIS
FOR THREE YEARS.
THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO IMPEACH
ME FROM THE DAY I GOT ELECTED.
AND, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY FAILED.
THIS IS THE EASIEST ONE OF THEM
ALL.
BECAUSE THIS ONE IS BASED ON ONE
CONVERSATION.
WHAT ABOUT OBAMA'S CONVERSATION
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF RUSSIA
WHERE HE SAYS, HEY, HEY, TELL
VLAD I WILL TALK TO HIM AFTER
THE ELECTION.
NOBODY REPORTS THAT, RIGHT?
THAT STUFF YOU SHOULD REPORT.
BUT YOU PEOPLE SHOULD BE ASHAMED
OF YOURSELVES.
WE HAVE THE MOST DISHONEST MEDIA
THAT YOU CAN IMAGINE AND YOU
SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF YOURSELF.
BUT HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED: THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WAS WRONG.
THE ONLY THING THAT MATTERS IS
THE TRANSCRIPT OF THE ACTUAL
CONVERSATION THAT I HAD WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE.
IT WAS PERFECT!
WE ARE LOOKING AT
CONGRATULATIONS, WE ARE LOOKING
AT DOING THINGS TOGETHER, AND
WHAT WE ARE LOOKING AT?
WE ARE LOOKING AT CORRUPTION.
BANG.
I BELIEVE IN 1999, THERE WAS A
RED CORRUPTION ACT OR CORRUPTION
BILL PASSED BETWEEN BOTH COUNTRI
BILL PASSED BETWEEN BOTH COUNTRS
BILL PASSED BETWEEN BOTH COUNTR.
I HAVE A DUTY TO REPORT
CORRUPTION.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
BIDEN'S SON IS CORRUPT, AND
BIDEN IS CORRUPT.
AND I'D RATHER RUN AGAINST BIDEN
THAN ALMOST ANY OF THOSE
CANDIDATES AND I THINK THEY ARE
ALL WEEK.
BUT I THINK BIDEN HAS NEVER BEEN
A SMART GUY AND HE'S LESS SMART
NOW THAN HE EVER WAS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Sean: AND THE PRESIDENT --
HE SUPPOSED TO EXECUTE THE LAWS
OF THE LAND.
THAT IT BE ELECTION INTERFERENCE
THAT PEOPLE USE TO CARE ABOUT.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO HAD POINTED
WORDS FOR HIS LYING, CORRUPT
MEDIA MOB AND I CALL THEM A MOB
FOR A REASON, BECAUSE THEY ARE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> BIDEN AND HIS SON ARE STONE
COLD CRICKET.
YOU KNOW IT.
HIS SON WALKS OUT WITH MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
THE KID KNOWS NOTHING.
YOU KNOW IT AND SO DID WE.
>> THE QUESTION IS WHAT DID YOU
WANT PRESIDENT ZELENSKY TO DO
WITH VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
HIS SON HUNTER?
>> ARE YOU TALKING TO ME?
>> IT'S A FOLLOW-UP OF WHAT I
JUST ASK YOU --
>> WE HAVE THE PRESIDENT OF
FINLAND -- ASKING THE QUESTION.
>> I HAVE ONE, BUT I WANT A
FOLLOW UP WHAT I ASK YOU --
>> DID YOU HEAR ME?
ASK HIM A QUESTION.
I GAVE YOU A LONG ANSWER.
AS THIS GENTLEMAN IN QUESTION.
DON'T BE RUDE.
>> NO, SIR, I DON'T WANT TO BE
RUDE BUT I WANT TO GIVE YOU AN
CHANCE TO ANSWER THE QUESTION --
>> THAT'S THE ANSWER.
IT'S A WHOLE HOAX.
DO YOU KNOW -- I SAY IN MANY
CASES, THE CORRUPT MEDIA BECAUSE
YOU ARE CORRUPT.
MUCH OF THE MEDIA IS NOT JUST A
SICK, IT'S CORRUPT.
>> Sean: CORRUPT, LIES,
WASTING TAXPAYER MONEY AND TIME,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, LIES,
HOAXES, THE MEDIA MOB, YOU MAY
WANT TO PAY ATTENTION.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO WIN
AND YOU'RE GOING TO HELP HIM.
THE PRESIDENT JUST RAISED A
WHOPPING $125 MILLION, A NEW
POLL HAVING THE PRESIDENT
CLIMBING TO A YEAR-LONG HIGH.
BY THE WAY, THE MOB MIGHT NOT
LIKE IT, BUT UNDER ARTICLE TWO,
SECTION THREE OF THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION THE
PRESIDENT HAS A SWORN DUTY TO,
"TAKE CARE THAT THE LAWS BE
FAITHFULLY EXECUTED."
THAT WOULD MEAN INVESTIGATING
ELECTION INTERFERENCE LIKE THE
HILLARY CAMPAIGN DID BY PAYING
FOR A DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER AND
LIKE WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON IN
UKRAINE.
THAT'S RIGHT, THE WEAPONIZATION